あの
太ったかもしれないあのねぇ
太ってかもしれないばあ
goo
加美北3年前くらいから燃やすという名称で呼ばれ続けてもう今に至りますけどもう
ちょっと燃やすじゃなくなってきたかもしれない僕はなんかずっと言われてたんですよ
色んな人に色んな人にもうほぼ100人に93人くらいの人に言われてたんですよあ
あー多分初めはタブ本ない体型だからお前はどれだけ食っても太らないから大丈夫なら
いいなぁたくさん食べてストンないメッツ言われ続けたんですけどね
じゃないか
ああああああああ
プールじゃないっ5分10取ったじゃないですかってほど違うじゃないああ
ああああああ
何を根拠に太らないんでとか言うんだよ
ふとロジャーん
me
はいというわけでちょっと待ってそもそもさん私の身長の平均体重を調べれば僕身長が
186センチなんでしょ
もう始まってるから俺始めてるから186センチの美容体型
狩りがにではなく細くてスタイルが良い体型の目安となる美容師表スタイルがいいと
いわれるね一般的な体型は69.1キロらしいですでに186センチの理想体型はな
12.6 k 標準体重より少しスタイリッシュな体験になる体重指標
72.6キロもで
れ体系は60号店じゃないけど俺じゃあ
少し前の所持前の俺だ一般的に女性が大変とお花前に目標とすると良いと言われる体重
指標が65.70らしいですね僕の心臓の標準体重が76.1 k
これが健康的な体するらしいです去年まではモデル体型
65キロピッタリぐらいでしたらちょっと最近ねあの温泉とか行くんですけれども
それとねもう著しくちょっとね増加がね顕著にみられたよちょっと測ってみます実際に
ちょっと1月僕の体型を見てほしいんですけどもそんなねめちゃくちゃ各地では太って
ないんですよ
どーーーんいやーでもまあ確かにね
太ってはないんですよあけどなんか出っ歯の任堂でとかがちょっとクリピなんでココと
かすごいもうホラードロロン部分
バッハ
バッハとれた
今だとかまで可能性で誓うでもはれますからねぇ
ある姉は特に筋肉があるわけでもなくて脂肪たっぷりいってわけでもなく打ったん
2になっちゃったプレイちょっと今の体長を測っていきましょうじゃあ測りますこれで
僕の体重きま
いきますよあっはぁ
par
ni
amaran
う2
rar
本当にまずはずキロぐらい太ってるから粘って待って待って待って本当にまずで焦るよ
人ならないと思ってたから
他のしんちゃんの理想体重702.6キロなので今ちょうど
普通の体操になりました
いうか室はやだなぁ俺普通やなあ普通じゃ嫌なんだ
つまりやらたーーー
ダイエットとまではいきませんがモデル体重まで絶対戻します
もうここでいいますただ去年みたいに置かせを禁止しますとか何かもう決まり方を作る
とストレスになるんで決まりことっ
くらずにちょっとダイエットしていきます65 k モデルたいというよりもドルから
多分ですねぼく体重増えたのいろんな心当たりがあるんですよ
運動不足もそうですし青カツ代
体験したリバウンドみたいなのもあると思う何禁止はして良かったたブラウンで掲示し
てなかったら本当にヤバい状況になってたと思う正しい判断だと思います part ね
なんか睡眠6足が太るらしいんですよ
それで一番の原因かなと思いましてあったらやっぱ青溝カップルらしいですよ
寝不足じゃねぇ俺で右側の木がてるんだけどやってるわけですね食べ物だけじゃないん
ですよ僕
こんなにできる通り下地2キロ太りましたからねもやしに戻るわけじゃないんですけど
もう6はやっぱり
スラっとしていたいと思う65 k て筋肉あったり頭はいいんですけどねまあそれが
理想なんですけどまずはとりあえず体重を戻すことから始めようと思いますいやー人
生活の70キロなんですよ冠たるか次僕が体重の話をするときは
モデル体型で会いましょう
じゃあ
me
バッハ
じゃあ
本当に痩せなきゃまず